Allah says in the Quran in surah Mis
4:21 he refers to the marriage the nikah
as the misak as a sacred covenant. The
marriage is a sacred covenant between
the husband and wife.
Allah says in the Quran in surah na
chter 4 verse number 19 do not inherit
the woman against her will against her
wishes.
Our
beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said it's mentioned in say
bkari had number 5066 the prophet said
oh young people the prophet said there
is no monasticism in Islam oh young
people whoever has the means to get
married should get married for it will
help you to lower your gaze and guard
your modesty.
So the prophet recommended that the
young men
and young women if they have the means
they should get married as soon as
possible.
There's a hadith of the prophet where a
prophet said marriage completes half
your dean.
So once during questions the time
someone asked me a Muslim man that does
it mean if I marry twice I will complete
my full dean.
What did the prophet mean when he said
marriage completes half your dean?
If you marry,
you prevent yourself from many fitnas
of fornication,
of opportunity,
of homosexuality, which are half the
evil in the world. Only if you marry, do
you have an opportunity to be a husband
or a wife. Only if you marry, do you
have an opportunity to be a father or a
mother, which are very important duties
in Islam. So if you marry
you get
opportunities
and duties which are half
and you save yourself for many of the
sins. That's the reason the prophet said
marriage completes half your dean. That
does not mean if you marry twice you
complete your full dean. If you marry
once or twice yet only half your dean is
complete.
In Islam,
we do not call
the woman as housewife.
In Islam, a woman is not married to the
house to be called a housewife.
You know, you find what is a profession
housewife.
In Islam, we call them homemakers
because they build their home.
They make the home. Homemakers.
Housewives.
That's the western concept.
You marry a woman to your house, then
you're called housewives. We prefer
calling the woman folk in Islam as
homemaker
because they build the home, they make
the home.
Allah says in the Quran in surah room
chapter number 30 verse number 21
that amongst his signs he has created
for you mates from amongst yourself
and has put love and tranquility into
your hearts.
Allah has put love and tranquility into
the hearts of the husband and wife.
in Islam.
According to say Bkari
had number 5138
once a woman she was forced by a father
to marry a man.
So the woman approaches the prophet
and the prophet says she has a right to
nullify the marriage.
It is mentioned in the humbul had number
2496.
Another hadith of Maja 1873 says that
the woman
went to the prophet to show to the other
Muslim woman that a father cannot force
her to give. But she continued with the
marriage. She did not mind but she
wanted to show to the other Muslim woman
that the permission of the woman and the
man is equally important for a marriage
to solommonize in Islam.